and where I'm interested in this subject
I have no connection to it whatsoever
other than as I often say the popsite
Geist ufology now that's not to say that
I haven't studied some of the same
things that uh that Ross has and other
people like Grant Cameron and others
that there is a cyclical nature to uh to
life on Earth that there are changes
evident in the fossil record and in um
sedimentary records
um and things like that so there may be
a great deal of conflation going on here
between what we call the entertainment
aspect of ufology and the need to
invigorate a subject and keep people
interested in it Vice the actual nuts
and bolts again and the reality of it
um species have gone extinct before
there's no reason to expect that we
won't go extinct someday uh so when
people talk about cataclysms I think
it's important that we don't conflate
them with um with popular apology I'd
like to leave that to the geologists and
to the climatologists and the other
people who are who are making that their
specific Focus
um I I you know I I I'm not sure it's
precisely what you're referring to I
mean cataclysms have always been been
part of of of human evolution
um you know in fact one could argue
we've always been on diverge of a
cataclysm at any moment our species uh
there have been been historical
anecdotes whether it's Nostradamus or
the Mayan calendar or even the Bible or
the Bible Gita or anything else
um you know
cataclysm Armageddon whatever has always
been part of of of of
the human
storytelling and for good reason because
you do have these these uh moments in
time where where things change so
dramatically case in point one could
probably point to to uh the last ice age
where where when when the Earth was
thawing out of the Ice Age I was a major
moment and caused a lot of species you
know to to to disappear because because
environments change uh the land bridge
when that was no longer crossable you
isolated certain uh genetic species from
from intermingling with each other
um you know it's it's always been part
of of who we are and always part of
Earth because Earth changes right look
at the dinosaurs right and and that was
a hell of a cataclysm right when you had
uh you had a meter come down and weigh
about 90 of of animals on this planet
um that's just reality that's not you
know I'm not sure that's necessarily
something we all need to to look at and
say oh you know that's coming we've
we've always been immersed in that again
you can look throughout history and see
where Mankind in almost every religious
text there is some sort of reference to
some sort of cataclysmic event or that
has occurred or will occur whether it's
the flooding stories of the earth uh and
the 40 days of of of of rain or other
you know pick your pick your story right
that we have always been telling
ourselves and that things continue to
happen world war three just another
example right
um nuclear war
um it's always it's always right around
the corner and and for good reason
because you have a lot of things
operating in nature that aren't
necessarily in favor for a species
survival and so you have to adapt if you
want to survive whether that's climate
or or because of things we do to each
other
um that's just the reality of life so
I'm not aware of any particular
cataclysm uh
Story You're maybe referring to because
frankly you know Pick Your Story du jour
it's